[Music]
what's up guys the island Lords podcast
back again from PAX East 2019 here at
the THQ Nordic booth I'm here with my
friend Toby from warhorse studios and
he's going to help us in playing the
fourth and final DLC for Kingdom Come
deliverance a woman's lot this will be
by far the biggest DLC we released so
far this is a heavy work-in-progress
build yes so you know guys work in
progress but it already gives you an
idea of what's happening so in this
woman's log DLC there are three major
paths one you play as Theresa B you get
your own dog and C there will be a big
quest time with Henry taking care of
some let's say Joan of Arc style
gameplay so what's the Theresa gameplay
like so first of all of course you will
play as Theresa woman slot
she will has weapons as well she can
dress of course women's clothes in that
case but she has her own RPGs skills as
well you will have a new sidekick thing
because the dog also have some RPG
skills so you can level that up so she
has a got a dog called tinker which has
some kind of sense of smell which means
how good is he and finding enemy's
treasures points of interest and so on
obedience the cook the dog will follow
you if you treat him well if you treat
him bad then he will run away scatter
and run away so you need to praise him
you need to feed him tell him good boy
and then he would be happy however if
the opponent attacks him and hurt him
then the obedience goes down so you take
care of your puppy there what's also
interesting is that Theresa will get her
own map so it's still on the kingdom
come
SMAP kind of but that's the outskirts of
silver Scala's
what you can see in the base game as
well however Teresa has her very own
silver skeleton map because the mines
which are around scallops will be
important in this DLC kind of and this
is even though in the base game the
player could already enter this area
Henry doesn't have that many reasons to
go there so it's kind of odd but you
because you don't have any question
right
okay new I can Teresa there so you might
know this area here we are right now at
the bottom of silver skeleton as carrots
is there on top and what we have here is
the home of Teresa and if you remember
in the very first minutes of the game
after the attack of silver scallops
you have to run away because bad things
happened and that's actually the very
same Road Henry is running down in this
quest of course I'm skipping some stuff
you have to go up fun thing is you can
meet Henry which means that you're you
use used to play Henry right and now you
can see me and third-person which is
weird about but there's some funny
gameplay between you and him the dork
will follow you and you can interact
with him let me show you how this
happens because this is before the
attack of silver scallops but everyone
knows who played keen who come that
terrible things are going to happen and
one of the terrible things is the tag of
Scala's so while the player did not see
this in the base game because you're
running away from that now Theresa has
to flee from this place but she doesn't
have the advantage to go in a safe place
like Henry she has to deal with the
injured people and this is her brother I
think so if you
to deal with the family her own family
and the people that are injured by this
by the attacks so what she has to do now
in this quest line is to actually help
to protect the brother and he needs
bandages and herbs so she's about to try
to look and get her those as fast as
possible
however there's an attack going on as
you can see and those attackers
Marauders are still here around so
Teresa is not a melee fighter she can
fight but well she's not that trained in
sword fighting same as Henry in the
beginning so he to find other ways and
she's a good stuff killer so be quiet be
stealthy kill them from behind use the
weapons you can find on their right so
you can now loot them take a look what
they have they have some hunting stuff
swords and so on use that but then again
you have the dog so maybe you can use
Tinker as well so sword fighting is a
good thing
bow shooting is better I could try to
aim at them it's a little bit tricky
though but what's way better is that you
can use tinker now SiC and you can send
him and he will attack or at least
distract those guys so they are not
attacking you both at the same time you
can demand how they are but give the dog
a second and he will take off the other
will take care of one of those guys in
in a minute
and he will be a big advantage to you
fighting a tinker this one is the dog of
Teresa Henry will get his own dog
there he goes thank you very much saw
the dog taking care of this one dude
attacked Inger yes get him however he
can also attack the dog as well and
remember the obedience thing if tinker
gets too many attacks haha gotcha very
good okay but
Tinka can do more than that attacking is
one thing
searching for quests stashes or whatever
that's what the dog is also good for now
we see something we know we remember
from base gains galets being burned
although that's a day after right we
survived as Teresa I'm loading so it
just skipping some parts and Tinker will
in a second run off because that's what
reduces that you can search for stuff so
if we talk to him and tell him seek then
he will try to look for a point of
interest he will now look for survivors
he will find them at Teresa will then
have to let me just skip this a little
bit I have to try to find surviving
people help them okay and this is a part
of a particular story
it's just very good question you can
trigger this quest okay
when Henry gets to the point that he got
saved by charissa then he asked Teresa
what the hell happened and she's
explaining what happened that's and this
is our living area and once you end this
DLC then you jump back into Henry's
story and continue on however this quest
line can be triggered at any point in
the game okay
after you survive the scale it's a tag
and then you just talk to Teresa and
then you can go on
this will be roughly five hours
okay and after you finish that and after
you you've done that Henry will also get
his dog so from that point and we will
have a dog being doing being able to do
the same things that it was a fast fast
we were able to do the same things as a
stinker here
okay all right you so much Toby for this
preview of a woman's lot the final DLC
for Kingdom Come deliverance look out
for it in May 2019 this is the allah
knows' podcast thank you